Sveglia alle 6. Meno di tre ore di
sonno e più di due settimane di
preparazione, e non so neanche perché sto
parlando con questa voce, ma funziona
Oggi sto per fare una cosa che sogno di
fare da tempo, insieme a una persona
speciale con la quale ho condiviso un
sacco di esperienze
Abbiamo visitato l'Asia, passato giornate
a giocare col make up, abbiamo lavorato
per l'Europa e ho pianto personalmente
come un  disperato quando le cose non
andavano benissimo. Sto parlando di una
ragazza,  anzi di un'amica speciale che mi
farà da Cicerone per la fiera di Lucca,
il Lucca Comics and Games. Questo video
a onor del vero, non sarebbe mai stato
possibile senza l'aiuto degli amici
di Trailine che è l'app, che mi sta
permettendo di fare questa esperienza
e della quale vi parlerò a brevissimo,
giusto il tempo di prendere il treno
Senza troppi fronzoli un'app così
...personalmente
...personalmente un'app...
personalmente, senza troppi fronzoli
un'app così ti svolta la vita, Io abito tra
Roma e Milano e per lavoro mi muovo
veramente ovunque in giro per l'Italia e
non sempre trovare il biglietto perfetto
è una cosa facile. Dicevo che grazie a
questa app un sacco di noie se ne vanno
La prima cosa che ti permette di
comprare in maniera veloce e intuitiva i
biglietti di, a parte treni diversi, ma
anche di pullman al fine di trovare
a parte quello che ti di torna più utile a te,
ma allo stesso tempo quello più
economico, e infine informazioni sul
treno che io di solito devo cercare in
stazione, un pochino chiedendo in giro,
guardando tabelloni, qua invece binari di
partenza, ritardi, le carrozze più
silenziose, le fermate, te le trovi tutte
quante all'interno del telefono e
secondo me è la svolta
Adesso sicuramente un'app come Trainline ti aiuta un sacco a vivere più
sereno ma non ti può aiutare a
sopportare quello che a volte può essere un
viaggio che estremamente noioso, ed è qui
che entro in gioco io
E ora provate a farlo anche voi: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Non è divertentissimo?
Ovviamente non vi darà risposte... ma provateci anche voi
Fissate il muro
accanto a voi e incominciate a parlare
Calcolate che i vostri amici
il più delle volte hanno lo stesso grado
di interesse per quello che dite
Si sa, la vita di ognuno di noi non sempre è
piena di avvenimenti come vorremmo che
fosse, ma quella del tuo vicino potrebbe
esserlo. Utilizzate la tecnica
dell' occhio a picchio di falco". Andate
leggermente indietro col busto, spostate
la testa verso l'orecchio del vostro
vicino e con un occhio a "picchio di
falco"  iniziate a spiare tutto quello che fa
Se la dea bendata è stata magnanima potrebbe
essere capitata quella volta su un
milione in cui state vicino a un bono
o a una bona. Perché guardare fuori dal finestrino
quando potete benissimo perdervi nei suoi occhi?
Non importa se avete la prima elementare, se siete
degli analfabeti, l'importante è che sappiate
che all'interno di una pagina i numeri
stanno in basso. Se stanno in alto state fingendo di leggerlo al contrario quel libro
A un certo punto del viaggio alzatevi dal
vostro posto e fingete di andare in bagno
A quel punto iniziate a passare da
carrozza 1 a carrozza ultima facendo
avanti e indietro, avanti e indietro, come un nuotatore olimpionico che fa i 1200 stile
Usate l'indice medio per correre lungo
il paesaggio che avrete di fianco. E' una
cosa che facevo anche in macchina
...assolutamente inutile, vi farà venire un
crampo alla spalla ma aiuterà sicuramente
a rendere il viaggio più veloce
Il Lucca Comics and Games, leggo testuali
parole del sito, è uno degli appuntamenti
più emozionanti in ambito europeo
riguardo fumetti, animazioni, e giochi di
ruolo e da tavolo, videogiochi e fantasy
Per arrivare alla mia destinazione ho
dovuto prendere un treno da Roma a
Firenze e poi fare un cambio con un
regionale pieno stracolmo di gente
direzione Lucca. Ora nonostante ci abbia scherzato su il
mio rapporto coi viaggi non è
assolutamente così negativo,  anzi, che sia
per lavoro, per amore, per hobby, per
curiosità o per avventura, a volte
allontanarsi dal proprio nido è un modo
perfetto non solo per scoprire il mondo
che ci circonda ma anche per scoprire un
pochino di più noi stessi. Culture
differenti, cibo straniero e forestiero o
addirittura esperienze che vivremo
solamente una volta nella nostra vita
stanno tutte e  fuori e aspettano
soltanto che hai  il coraggio di fare i
bagagli e aprire le ali
magari con un grande amico a farti compagnia
come nel mio caso, con lei, Alice
- Io son felicissima che sei arrivato a Lucca!
- Allora, come funziona? Io non ci sono mai
stato - Allora, ci sono un sacco di
padiglioni in giro per la città, adesso andiamo di qua
- Tu sai tutto? - Si - L'unica cosa però che dico è
che non possiamo andare così
- In che senso non possiamo andare così?
- Non possiamo andare così, dobbiamo vestirci - Ma da che ci vestiamo? - Ci ho pensato io
Ho pensato alla mia maschera e alla
tua maschera
- No in che senso? - E' una cosa molto... Quando  l'ho pensata mi ha ricordato molto... tipo te al mare
Ti metterei mai in imbarazzo? - Si
-  Lo ricordavo un filino diverso
- Allora Ali, vai, è qua dentro  -  Oh mi piace! - No aspetta, no no no questo no questo non è tuo
- Ma guarda come mi sta bene - Aspetta ti faccio vedere qual è il tuo - Ma che cos'è? Guglielmo! Che cos'è?
Ma che cos'è? Va bene tutto, ma questo coso che cos'è? - Serve per dare un effetto robotico, ok ?
- Sei pronto per il  sabato sera?
- N o perché poi c'è comunque...  vedi questa
specie di mutanda? Va messa sopra. "Il marsupio sisi". Hai presente? Dai Ali, ci sta
- Devo dire che hai azzeccato la taglia , ti ringrazio. Ora la mia silhouette è messa in risalto da questo...
- Hai capito? Cioè è fatto apposta tipo... - Una clessidra
Non mi si tirano su le braccia.... E c'è quello a v
- Eh ma non è il contrario? - Ah dici  che davanti
c'è lo scollo? - Ma che sei una sposa con lo scollo a v dietro? - ♫ Sabato sera alla discoteca ♫
- "Sono tua madre!" - Guglielmo! - Guarda... io non so esattamente...
mentre mi sfilo il guanto in maniera lasciva
"Sono tuo padre"
Eh? - Oh, mi è caduto un qualcosa... ok - Guglielmo, non mi sembro tanto carina - Questo è perché sei deliziosa!
- Io non son contenta di questa...
- Una. Vai con la  maschera anche - (*risate*) - Ma la smettete?
Poi gli hanno messo le mutande sopra capito? Avevi detto che era carino! - Te la senti di fare un giro? - Si
- Tu calcola che nessuno ti riconoscerà - Ah bene, menomale! - Neanche se togli la maschera
Neanche se togliesse la maschera nessuno la riconoscerebbe
No Gu, si è aperto! - Si è rotto il cranio - Vai siamo pronti? - Considera che c'è chi è messo peggio di te (Enrico)
- Scusa, stai parlando di qualcuno in particolare?
bene
no
il mondo
la classe cioè non capiamo perché ci
chiedono le foto siamo vestiti bene o
hanno veramente cattivo gusto
no niente
guarda
e tv mm venerdì sera e sabato mattina
no molto perché non restino non sono i
punti per l'aria
è vero
sguardi di approvazione io penso di aver
fatto una banda di interpretazione
un albero
un fenomeno
bene bambino l'unica persona che
potrebbe mai prendere con sede a verso
damiano la maschera ma niente liner
vieni stress test incredibile di provole
spider man di nusco il secondo avviso da
onore
vogliamo davvero
vergogna
dico solo che gli anni e siamo insieme
grazie a guglielmo la prima volta che ho
scritto agnese sapendo che era fan ho
scritto io mi sono fatto mandare da lui
il video di saluto le ho scritto da
livorno
lei ha detto ti devo una birra possiamo
andare a prendere a birra e poi bene sia
innamorata sia chi ovviamente
ho visto una ventina ragazzi la mia
prima esperienza a lucca comics finisce
qui grazie a dice per avermi fatto da
cicerone grazie 3 line preferite mi6
fare questa esperienza meravigliosa
fondamentalmente dice tu sei stata utile
relativamente grazie non si nota
differenza